(upbeat music)
- Welcome to "Ear Biscuits",
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Link.
- And I am Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are getting to know the latest addition
to the Neal household.
Jasper.
- A dog.
I got another freaking dog, y'all.
So we got Jade.
- He's here.
- We got Saka, the cat.
- He's here. He's hiding under the table.
- He's hiding in the wings.
And he's gonna show himself.
- What if the wings are your lap?
Yes.
I can see him right now.
He's very Jade like that
he's just in your lap,
but no complaints.
- Remember that, 'cause
that's a big factor in this.
But yeah.
So, we've got three
animals in the Neal house,
now that we got Saka the
cat and Jasper the dog,
and I wanted to introduce all of you
loyal Ear Biscuiteers to the
new wildlife in the family.
- My phone is like...
It's responding like Siri is listening.
- Constantly.
- What if you stopped talking?
Will it stop listening?
- I don't like the feeling of
being constantly listened to
while having a conversation.
- Won't it eventually realize
that we're not talking to it?
- You mean her?
- No, it's it.
- Okay.
- I don't give that kind
of personhood to Siri.
- Well, I think you might
need to hit the thing
because even that glowing orb
that indicates that it's
constantly listening
is gonna run down your battery.
I mean that thing's a battery sucker.
- Oh look, she just took
all that information
and then just said, "One sec."
- Oh, so the entire
intro to "Ear Biscuits."
Let's see how she responds.
- She's still working.
- You see you're saying she now.
- Okay. It's still working.
- What's gonna happen?
- Well, I don't even know
what she's working on.
- I'm working on that.
- What are you working on?
What do you mean you're working on that?
- I mean, we gave it a lot.
- Yeah, something went wrong.
That's right, Siri.
- Let's not try again.
Let's just keep going. How about that?
So yeah, I'm gonna tell you
all the introductory struggles
and experiences associated with adding
a third animal and a second dog
into the Neal household,
as we are slowly creeping
out of quarantine.
You know us?
Averse to change.
- You're not averse to new animals though.
- No, we're not.
- Which is, we will
discuss the irony in that.
- I did not know it was gonna happen,
but it makes total sense in retrospect.
But I wanted to start out
just giving you an update
and I've got another experience that I had
on some recent travels.
And I just didn't know
if I was going crazy.
So I kinda need you to
tell me that I'm good.
- Well, I'm not gonna judge
whether or not you're crazy
based on one experience.
- Well, you can add it to the annals...
- I take the whole of your...
Well, everything that I know about you.
- I said annals and you said whole.
Okay, that's fine.
Let's get into-
- Anal hole is not anything.
Anal hole is is just a hole
where you keep records.
- Okay, well, let's dig deep
and see what we conclude.
- Everybody should have
one in their basement.
- We took a family trip to visit a campus.
Campus was entirely
closed, but there's a lot,
we could walk around outside
because Lily was accepted to this place.
I'm not gonna say the place
because I don't wanna
talk about the place.
That's not what this-
- But it's Harvard.
- That's not what this is about, but yeah,
it's definitely Harvard
and Yale at the same time.
- Right, she's going to both of 'em.
She's doing a double major
between Harvard and Yale.
And it means majoring in both places.
- There's a tunnel that connects them.
We wanted to see what
this tunnel was about.
You know, this Harvard, Yale tunnel.
- The most elite of college experiences.
The Harvard, Yale double major.
- So we went to college and just to kinda
really give a sense of,
hey, this is happening.
You've been accepted here.
You're most likely gonna go here.
Let's wrap our minds around the fact
that you are going to college
and we all need to kinda
get with the program.
- Who was this trip for?
What percentage of like...
- It was mostly for Lily, but yeah.
I think it's definitely for-
- That's what I meant.
- I mean, for me and Christy,
it was like still coming to grips
and starting to prepare emotionally.
And I think Lily's anxious.
It's a huge life change.
The biggest one she's
ever experienced maybe.
- Besides being born.
- And for Lincoln, I wanted
him to be there to be like,
okay, I'm just, this coming
year, his junior year,
he's gonna start-
- He's gotta start thinking about this.
- He's gotta start thinking
about it and gear up for it.
- Did you see any evidence of that?
- We weren't gonna leave Lando home alone.
- Did you see any evidence
that Lincoln was beginning
to think about it?
(both laugh)
- It's not the type of thing you see.
Like, I can't look at his face
and tell like, any wheels are turning.
- What did he say though?
He was like, "Oh, college."
- It reminds me.
Ben told me the other day.
Ben's on camera again for
"Good Mythical Morning."
So he's like one of the
closest people to us,
almost as close as we
are to each other on set.
And in-between takes or something,
he was like, "Are you
angry? You look angry."
He kinda leaned in.
I was like, "No, I'm just thinking.
- Yeah. Right.
- When I think I just look angry.
Like if I'm really thinking?
- I think actually both
of us have a tendency
to look angry while thinking.
- We've got thinking angry face.
- One of the things I've noticed this year
and being in so many Zoom calls,
is that our resting Zoom call face,
both of us look a little bit judgy.
And I would say even Stevie as well.
So like, when you've got
me and you and Stevie-
- But that means we're engaged.
- Who are really engaged with you,
'cause we had some people
pitching us some things and-
- Yeah, they're doing all the talking.
- And I think about how I feel
when I'm on the other end
of that pitch process.
And I know that there are people
who have a very warm, sort
of resting smiley face,
an acceptance face, accepting face.
And I love talking to those people
but I am very well aware that
I am not one of those people,
you're not one of those people,
and Stevie's is also
not one of those people.
- And when you're on Zoom,
you can see everybody's face.
I mean, it's not like being
in a room where you're like,
you could see everybody at
once and you can be drawn
to the person who looks the angriest.
- I had to remind myself in...
- It helps to be able to see yourself.
- I go, like...
- A little smirk.
Well, Mallory does a good job.
- She's great.
- Mallory's our head of development.
Yeah, I can see her.
Like if I'm looking at the person talking,
I can look over there
and see anybody else.
- She's got a good listening face.
- She nods and she smiles.
She's being supportive.
- But you might look at us and say,
"These guys are having the
worst day of their lives."
- We're not making it easy,
but we're not doing it on purpose.
So, and this is a nice teaser
for what we're gonna talk about
in the next episode of "Ear Biscuits,"
because we're talking about being
on the receiving end of that.
- Rejection.
- Us trying to develop ideas.
And we've decided to...
So next week, we're gonna give you this.
I didn't mean to make
this a teaser right now,
but we're gonna give you a download
of all of these ideas and
projects in the traditional realm.
For years, we've been adding to a list
of projects that we've been trying
to get off the ground.
- All the things that
people have said no to,
that we'd never talk about.
And so we're gonna share all
of those projects with you.
So if you're not into...
- It's a lot of stuff.
- Into dogs or colleges
or anything like that,
then next week is gonna
be just about, yeah,
all the projects that have been squashed,
along with our hearts, question mark.
Might make it a two-parter.
I don't know.
There's a lot to unpack
there, but we'll start
with just all the ideas we've had.
Yeah, I've done some digging there.
I wanna see what you remember.
But anyway, back to the story.
So we take a road trip
and we got an Airbnb.
'cause we were gonna stay there the night,
get up the next day,
spend basically all day
walking around what's
basically a deserted campus
but still a very cool campus.
And I will go ahead and tell
you, it was a great experience.
I think Lily was confirmed,
more confirmed in her
decision to go there.
So I'd say she's at like almost 90% now.
She's on a couple of waiting lists.
And so getting those answers
and making those decisions
will make it official, but
it was totally worthwhile.
But I wanna talk about this Airbnb.
I'm not gonna talk about
the college stuff at all.
'cause then we stayed there the next night
and then drove back the next day.
So we stayed there two nights.
Now, this is a nice Airbnb.
It had four bedrooms.
And so everybody, every
kid got their own room.
They were excited about that.
But I knew reading the
description and the reviews
that this was the house that...
It was a permanent residence
of the family that lived there.
A couple and their two sons.
- And so the Airbnb, if they
go out of town or something.
- Well, apparently.
- I have relatives who have done that.
Who Airbnb their house
when they go on vacation.
Why not?
You make a little scratch.
- I've stayed at a lot of Airbnbs
so I have a lot to compare it to,
but I didn't think anything of the fact
that this was a permanent
residence until we get there.
And there's, I mean, it's
not like they're everywhere,
but there are pictures.
- Personal items.
- Of the family.
And there are-
- Personal effects.
- There's a couple of
grandparent pictures.
And then in the pantry,
there's a clean shelf.
And then above it, there's
a shelf full of stuff
that says do not eat.
- Do not eat.
- Do not touch, and there
was some cereal there.
And boy, I had a difficult time.
I was very tempted.
- Oh, that's tough.
They should put that in a cage.
- They did let us use their coffee.
But still I wasn't
thinking too much about it.
You know, that night,
after we watch "Survivor."
No matter where we are on the planet,
if the sun's gone down, the
Neals have to watch "Survivor."
I'm tucking Lando into bed.
And Christy comes in there
and we're tucking him into bed.
And it's a bunk bed room.
And apparently these
boys, it's the boys room
that they share.
And Lando just looks concerned.
And so I'm like, "Buddy, what's going on?"
He was like, "Well, people live here.
This is somebody's room.
I feel kinda weird about it."
And then he said, "I feel
like Elias is here with me."
(Rhett laughs)
And I'm like, "You know this boy's name?"
- This is like the
beginning of a horror movie.
- I was like, "Please tell
me he is not visible to you
and speaking to you right now."
- How did he get his name?
- On the front door, it's like, Elias
and whatever his brother's
name is room, like says it.
And then it's like,
got all of their books,
their toys and all their stuff.
- But why did he feel
like only Elias was there?
Elias and Toby.
It is creepier that only Elias is there.
- I know.
- And his name is Elias,
which is a perfect horror movie name.
- And when he said that-
- Elias is here with me.
- I kinda looked at
Christy and I was like,
I knew my mission was to just blow it off.
But I couldn't help but
acknowledge within my own self
that when he said that,
it kinda creeped me out.
So I'm like, listen,
everywhere we've stayed,
people have stayed there.
Like a typical Airbnb, like a hotel,
I mean, every day there's
somebody new staying there.
Every week, there's
Yeah, you're sleeping in Elias' bed.
- But that's the difference.
Elias's spirit is much more present
in a place where he lives.
- You're feeling Lando's vibes.
First of all, that whole track
that I was on didn't help,
because it was like, oh my gosh,
you mean all the other places I've been,
there's been hundreds
and thousands of people
that have slept there?
And he didn't know what to
be more disturbed about.
And as I was saying it,
come to think of it,
neither did I.
- You even thought about this?
As much as you enjoy Airbnbs.
- I don't like to think about...
People talk about the
black light of it all.
especially at hotels, but I
have a higher trust in Airbnbs.
It's a different type of travel.
- That's your mistake because-
- I don't want to hear it.
- The nanny cams.
I mean, there's hidden
cameras in all Airbnbs.
No. Okay.
For legal reasons, I can't say that.
There has to be hidden cameras.
- That can't be legal.
- Of course, it's not legal.
It's highly illegal and you can get
to a lot of trouble for it.
But I'm just saying that
people are nuts, man.
- Do you think about that
when you stay at an Airbnb?
- Yeah, I go into...
- You look for cameras?
- I assume that I'm being recorded
when I'm in an Airbnb.
- Teddy bears where one
eyeball is a lot darker
than the other one?
- It's never that obvious.
I just assume I'm being recorded.
- Are you telling you've found a camera?
You've never found a camera.
- No, I just assume I'm being recorded,
and I act like I'm on a reality show.
So sometimes there's a little...
I get a little bit angry about something,
but it's just for the camera.
- Okay, as long as there's a resolution
at the end of the 22 minutes.
- And especially during
certain activities,
I really think about the cameras.
- Oh God!
- You gotta get the angles right?
- So, I didn't know what to
say to help him feel better.
So I just was like,
"Hey, it's no big deal."
And his last words as I
was leaving the room were,
"I feel like Elias is sleeping with me."
And I was like, "Don't put it like that."
(Rhett laughs)
- But he was kinda messing
with you a little bit.
He thought it was funny.
He wasn't really scared.
- No, this is coming from a place
of this is what he's thinking.
But based on me and Christy's reactions,
he did kind of cool off a little bit.
He did sleep in the bed
and he ended up being fine,
but I went downstairs
and I ended up watching
some stuff with Christy
and then she goes to bed and
I'm the only one downstairs.
All of our bedrooms are upstairs.
And then I'm turning off the lights
and getting ready to head upstairs.
I go to the front door and I lock it.
And then to the right of the front door,
as I'm walking back, there's
another door that's closed.
- Owner's closet.
Well, and then I realize
this is not a closet.
This is the door to their garage.
We couldn't park in the garage.
We had to walk around
it to the front door,
but there's a door right there.
And with all the lights off,
I noticed something I hadn't seen before.
There was light spilling
out from the bottom
and a little bit of the sides,
up the sides of this door.
- That means there's a light on
on the other side of the door.
- Exactly.
There's a light on in this garage.
- Okay.
- And I stood there
and I realized I was
kinda getting freaked out.
Now you've seen "Parasite."
- Yeah.
- I started to think that
the family was in the garage,
because I've been wondering...
I knew the family was still in town
'cause I was in contact with the wife
about some things.
- You think Elias,
his mom and dad and his
little brother, Toby
or whatever his name
is, go into the garage
and then let a family of
five stay in their house?
- Yeah.
And I think that they're all-
- This seems implausible.
- I was just standing there in the dark
with the light spilling
around the edge of the door,
staring at the door knob and thinking,
Elias and his family are
huddled in that garage
just trying to make some extra scratch.
Waiting for us to leave.
And they're listening to
all of our conversations.
I mean, it's like the
webcam thing, but worse.
And then, I make up my
mind and I slowly...
- You should open it quickly.
- Reach for the knob.
I grab the knob.
And I turn it.
It's locked.
- Yeah, 'cause they're in there.
- They've locked themselves in there.
- Yeah. Yeah.
They're in there huddled in a circle.
- And I adjusted it a few more times
and then I just like
stood back and I was like,
oh, now they know I'm on to 'em.
And I just went upstairs and went to bed.
End of story.
- They're in there pooping in buckets.
- I know.
It's like, I mean-
- It's sad, actually.
- Do they have another...
It's a permanent residence.
Do they have another house in town?
I know they were still in town.
'cause I know they came back when we left.
Because of, I got a message after checkout
pretty quickly from her, and
I'm pretty sure it was her.
- They probably have another family
that they can go and stay with,
because the town that they're in
is a town that people would want to visit.
- Or they could be in the garage.
- They're not in the garage.
I can safely say that, but you
were being filmed for sure.
- Well, the laugh's on them
because now I'm exploiting
it for a podcast.
- I mean, let's just assume
that they're not in the garage
and they just left the
light on in the garage,
which is probably the more likely thing,
do you feel differently
about staying in...
Are there other differences, but staying
in somebody's house that
is a designated Airbnb
where it's not a permanent residence?
- Once Lando got in my head, man,
I am definitely team not
permanent residence Airbnb.
I definitely think that's right
because you kinda wanna
make a space your own.
But I would say that maybe every 10th time
you stay in an Airbnb,
you should stay in one
that's a permanent residence
because to me, a lot of...
You know me, I think a
lot about the apocalypse
and I think about what it's gonna be like
to just go into people's homes
after the world has ended.
- Oh, you're into this.
- And like just assume their life.
- You're like rustling
through their books?
I mean, in the bedroom,
are you looking through their drawers?
Christy and I slept in their bed.
- Yeah, but again, like you said earlier,
in a hotel bed, you're sleeping in a bed.
- It's better. Yeah.
- You're sleeping in a bed
that so many other people have slept in.
And people do things.
- I've never thought about this stuff.
This is Lando's fault.
- People do things
in hotel beds that they
won't do in their own beds.
- Oh yeah, yeah. That's right.
- Yeah, they're like, this is a hotel bed.
- From personal experience.
- We don't have to worry
about breaking this bed.
- What have you done?
- I mean, you have to
watch some of the tapes
that people have made of me,
that are somewhere on some website.
The Airbnb files.
It's called analhole.com.
- Oh gosh!
(both laugh)
Oh gosh.
I mean, I definitely felt
like I was under more scrutiny
to take good care of their house,
but Christy had an opposite effect.
When we were leaving-
- She was gonna miss it.
- She went to a local plant
shop and she bought a plant
and gave it and left it with a note.
- 'cause you know that there's somebody
who's gonna experience
it and appreciate it.
- Well, she felt like she
had gotten to know 'em.
- Yeah. Right, yeah.
It's not just people passing through.
This is their space.
- I mean she was wearing
the wife's underwear.
She went through her
drawer and she was like,
"Oh, should I get something like this?
What about something like this?
- So they didn't have any locks
on their drawers?
- Underwear drawers?
Nope.
- Now, 'cause I recently
stayed at an Airbnb
and there was one, there were two doors.
One closet that was locked.
- Yeah, there's always
the closet that's locked.
- And then a weird handle-less,
hinge-less door in the bathroom.
Actually in the bathroom,
in the toilet closet.
They have one of those bathrooms
that just has a little toilet room?
- Oh wow. Another room from in there?
- And then there was a
little room in there,
and it said, it had, they
had done a lot of labeling.
- Yep.
- Owner's private closet.
- And they were in there, dude.
- I think it meant to say
owner's closet, private.
- Was there light
emitting from the cracks?
- No, the family wasn't in there.
- They were squatting in there.
- But I will say...
- They came out when you went to sleep.
- I could not get into it despite trying.
And it wasn't because I wanted to get in
and get into the owner's private closet,
it was that there wasn't a handle.
And I was like, well, how do
they get into this closet?
Do I push on it? Do I pull on it?
Do you need a crowbar?
I didn't do any damage
to it, but while taking-
- You got frustrated
and just kicked it in.
- While doing a BM, which I was probably
on the pot for seven to eight minutes,
which I know is more than you really need.
But I spent a lot of time trying to,
while my pants were
completely around my ankles,
try to get into this private closet.
- It was a short closet?
- Oh yeah.
I would have had to...
- They're really hunkered down.
- Squat, but I was already squatting.
So if I had gotten it open,
I would have just rolled off the toilet
right into the closet.
- I mean, my biggest critique
besides all of the critiques
directed toward Lando,
who basically ruined my trip.
There was a squeegee in the shower.
Now, much respect.
We don't have that, but I've
certainly thought about it.
But to leave a squeegee
out for your guest to use
is a bit much.
That's a bit heavy handed.
Because here I am squeegeeing
somebody else's shower.
- So you took the bait?
- The glass door.
Yeah, it was there.
I felt like I had to do the squeegee.
- Was it hanging on something
or was it sitting in the shower?
- It was propped up on
the floor of the shower
against the door.
- Yeah, that's offensive.
- Yeah, I should have taken this squeegee.
They can afford-
- You should have broken something.
- Two days of not squeegeeing.
- You should have broken a lamp.
- It kinda sent the wrong message.
- The best thing to do...
- You're being watched from the garage.
- If you ever wanna take revenge
on somebody in an Airbnb,
first of all, just for legal purposes,
this is for entertainment purposes only.
This is a fun thing to do.
You take a lamp.
Don't get a nice lamp, get a lamp
that looks like it was maybe,
just like a Bed, Bath & Beyond purchase.
You know what I'm saying?
And crack it.
- Crack it.
- Crack it with something.
- Break it.
- Break it, but break it
so that it still stays together.
- Okay.
- And if it comes apart,
put it back together
in a way that it's sort of standing
and then everything looks awesome.
And then when they get home
and they reach to turn on the lamp,
the whole thing falls apart
and they think they did it.
Yeah.
This is to take revenge.
If they do something offensive
like leave a squeegee out for you to use.
- Oh, it's like, look,
you broke your own lamp,
that, spoiler alert, is not your lamp.
Oh my gosh, I just broke this lamp
that they left for us as a gift?
- No, you're not
understanding what I'm saying.
- Nope.
- You break an existing
lamp of theirs in revenge,
but you make them think that they did it.
- But I bought the lamp.
- No, no, no.
You make sure that you pick a lamp
that doesn't look like it's too expensive.
That's why I said Bed, Bath & Beyond.
- I thought you said buy
it from Bed, Bath & Beyond.
- You need to be able to look at lamps
and decipher their values,
which is something I can do.
- Create a booby trap.
- I think I've proved it.
- Booby traps.
Okay. All right, that's cool.
That's cool.
All right, let me tell you about my dog.
But first, let me tell you about this mug.
You put hot liquid in it and it reveals.
Here, you hold yours up in front of mine.
Yours has cold liquid in it.
And then you remove it and
you put hot liquid in it,
it turns into that or turn it around.
- This is even cooler on this side.
A whole Cocker tree is breathing fire.
- Put hot liquid in it.
- [Rhett] It's magic.
- Mine simulates having
hot liquid constantly.
Get it at mythical.com.
You see it on the desk of
"Good Mythical Morning,"
if you watch that show.
Or maybe you're just into this one
and you're seeing it right
now for the first time.
Get that design revealing heat
activated mug, mythical.com.
Jasper, come here.
- Your dog's running around.
Sniffing.
- He got tired
of being in my lap.
Okay. Come here, buddy.
I want everybody to meet ya.
This is Jasper.
Today on "Good Mythical Morning,"
we brought him out.
- Yep.
- And you've met him.
You've hung out with him a little bit.
He likes to...
Let me move this over
here so he can see you.
He likes to just lay right under my chin.
And he's so sweet.
He's a sweetheart.
Look at him.
- Well, he's sweet to some people.
- I've always been jealous of
how, when you hold Barbara,
Barbara will lean her
head against your chest.
Like that's something Jade
doesn't do, but he does it,
and it feels so good.
Like, this is so worth it, man.
All of the problems and trials
that I'm gonna tell you about are worth it
because he's a sweetheart.
We got him on February 20th.
So we've had him a while.
I've been kind of keeping it under wraps,
because, I mean we talked
about the cat on the show
and like, by the time
that episode came out,
we had already gotten Jasper and I'm like,
I don't wanna go that
hard with pet episodes.
People are gonna start rolling their eyes.
But I had to show him off because-
- [Rhett] He's gone to sleep.
- He's a little baby.
He's like a little baby.
- Let me see if I can pet him.
Hey, bud.
- Well, he thinks that it's my hand.
No.
- Hey, buddy.
- Yeah.
That's good.
- Don't look so skeptical.
Don't look so skeptical.
- He has his issues.
How did this begin?
I mean, you know when we got Saka,
I was telling you that Christy was like,
"Well, I wanted to get a dog.
I didn't wanna get a cat."
And I'm thinking, well, we're
not gonna get a dog now.
Of course I was wrong.
She had been looking at adoption pictures
and stuff like that.
And my stipulation was,
if we can get a dog that looks like Jade,
I want another Jade, but
in a different color.
If you can show me one of
those dogs, then I'm listening.
But I'm not interested in getting a dog.
I'm interested in getting
a sibling to Jade.
- Now, you tell me, since you know
what you wanna talk about,
how much time do you wanna spend
talking about that
particular aspect of this?
And have you talked to
your therapist about it?
(Link laughs)
- No, I haven't.
We can talk about that.
- 'cause I just wanna know.
I haven't really thought about it.
I find it very Link-ish
that that was a stipulation.
And I was just wondering, have you thought
about why that's the case?
- Yeah, I'm so attached to Jade.
Jade is my dog.
Jasper is Christy's dog, first of all.
That's what's happened
and I'm fine with that.
And Jade is the queen and
she's the queen of my heart.
She's what I think some
people call heart dogs.
You have this one dog
that changes how you feel
about dogs and pets in general.
And so, yeah, I have this
like deeply rooted connection
and love of Jade that like,
I don't want a dog to replace Jade,
but everything I love about Jade,
I would insist in being in another dog.
Like, a dog that just
lets you hold him or her
like a baby or like a cat.
Everything that, yeah, the fact
that Jade doesn't do anything.
- I understand all that.
But I'm saying specifically
wanting to look the same.
Because that's the only
thing that I'm talking about.
- Oh, just looking the same.
Well, no, because looking the
same means a similar breed,
which means acting very similar.
And I mean, as you can see,
he's just laying here on the table.
He has a very similar temperament to Jade.
And I assume that like,
if you get the same breed
or similar breed, breeds are so different.
So like with a long haired
miniature dachshund mix,
you know what your problems are.
Like, we've dealt with the...
There's a lot of problems
with house breaking
and training a dachshund.
But you get a lot of good stuff
with like the cuddliness
and the, you know,
just the lay around.
They don't have a lot of energy
and they'll sleep with you in the bed.
So it's like, you take
the good with the bad
but it's a known entity.
- I misinterpreted it
unless you're only giving me
half of the reason.
Because I thought that you
wanted the dog to look like Jade.
It wasn't a necessarily a breed thing.
It was like, does her face
look exactly like Jade's face?
Because that's what you kept saying.
That's what you were vocalizing.
- Yes, that's what I boil
it down to from my criteria.
So then Christy shows
me the picture of Jasper
and I was like, 'cause I'm following
all of these miniature
dachshunds on Instagram.
And there's these that are
like peanut butter colored.
And I was like, "That's what I want.
I want a peanut butter colored Jade."
And so Christy's mission
apparently was to find Jasper.
And so she showed me the
picture and I'm like...
And she's like, we know the foster mom.
She's here in town.
Lincoln played baseball with her son.
So we knew her years ago.
And so like, there was
even more of a connection.
We're like, all right,
we'll visit this dog,
but here's the thing.
We can set an appointment
for this coming Saturday.
We can go there as a family,
we can check out Jasper
'cause it's only one picture.
You don't know exactly what they're hiding
or what the full story is.
- It might just be a dog that's ahead.
- And kids, you gotta
be prepared for that.
So I said, "Listen, we're not gonna go
and get attached to this dog
and then have to adopt it,
and have this awkward conversation
in front of this foster mom."
What we're gonna do is, we're
gonna check out the dog.
We're gonna spend some time with it
in this woman's front
yard with our masks on,
and then we're gonna leave.
And then when we get back in
the car and get back home,
we're gonna each say what we think
and we're gonna give our assessment,
and we're gonna vote basically to see
if we want to adopt this dog.
- And you can do that in your family
'cause you got five people.
Votes actually matter.
- That's right.
- If our family votes on something,
we got to bring Kamala Harris
in to actually break the tie.
- That's cool, man.
- Yeah. I've got her on speed dial.
- That is cool.
So we get there and the description
of Jasper before we got there was,
wait, he's 11 months old.
His family, his parents
were owned by someone
and they wanted to keep him
but then they couldn't
afford to get him fixed.
So they ended up giving
him up for adoption
because they couldn't get him fixed.
And he is super lovable.
This is the description.
And he will want to sleep with you.
And we're like, this sounds great.
We want him to sleep with us.
This is, Jade's been sleeping with Lincoln
because she started waking up more often
and giving us bad night's sleep.
Lincoln's got a bigger bed
and he's not sleeping with a woman.
So he can just sleep with the dog.
He's got a lot more room.
So our bed's empty.
So I'm like, well,
we're gonna do our plan.
We're gonna assess the dog
then we're gonna leave.
It's funny how he's just
laying on the table.
This is just like he did
in "Good Mythical Morning."
Jade doesn't do this if
you put Jade on the table.
- You gotta watch yourself
rubbing that belly though.
There's a penis.
- This one's got a wiener.
The other one doesn't have a wiener.
Oh, and look, he's got
a tattoo right there.
Look at that.
- What is that for?
- I think that's where
they put the microchip in.
- Oh, they put a little tattoo.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Right next to your wiener.
That's interesting.
That's where I'd get it.
- I'm thinking about it.
Put like an arrow and then like
like a caption or something.
Caption this.
So we get there and
this dog has a cone on,
and I'm like, "Ooh, a cone."
'cause he had just been fixed.
So he doesn't lick his own fixture.
After a few seconds, I'm like,
"Well, can we take this cone off?"
'cause I'm thinking, I
cannot assess this dog
with a cone on, like,
that's not gonna happen.
We can put the cone back on afterward.
So she takes the cone off.
He is so clingy to this woman.
She's a blonde woman, foster mom.
So just like Christy's blonde.
But then, so then she
hands Jasper to Christy
and then he just curls
up and he's so timid.
And she said, "He's really clingy,
he follows me around everywhere.
He wants me to hold him all the time."
And I'm like, hmm.
So he's got this separation anxiety,
where he has to be with
her the whole time.
Now, Christy's holding him
and he's putting his head on her neck.
And then I was like,
"Let me hold this dog."
Now. I was like, dang, this
dog got some long legs.
Like, I mean, look at
the legs on this dog.
This is crazy.
- [Rhett] Do you know where
the leg length comes from?
- We think that he is long
hair dachshund and Pomeranian.
So we're thinking-
- Okay.
- But we don't know for sure.
- Pomeranians have long legs?
- I thought.
That's what Christy told me.
- I don't know about that.
I thought maybe part deer.
- I was like,
he's so much taller than Jade.
He's like a deer, but his
face looks like Jade's face.
These are the things that I'm thinking.
And then I hold the dog and
I'm like, oh, he's so cuddly.
- So he let you hold him the first time?
- He was really scared.
- But he didn't growl at you?
- No. Well, no, he didn't.
But he definitely likes
women a lot better than guys.
Like, he's growling at you.
- Both when we recorded him on GMM
and also this morning, like,
if I just walk into the office,
like, he's fine with me right now.
He lets me touch him, he's not growling,
he doesn't seem too skeptical.
In fact, just a second ago
when he was laying there
and I stopped petting him.
He hit me with his nose
to get me to keep going.
But if I walk into the room
and he's just like on the
floor, immediate aggression.
Well, fear that then
turns into aggression.
- So I was holding him.
I look over at the kids.
They're like taking him in, analyzing him,
but they could tell
that I'm inspecting him.
I'm inspecting him everywhere,
looking at his teeth.
Measuring, like, is this arm too long?
- Like a dog judge that
knows nothing about dogs.
- Yeah, yeah.
Like, lifting the tail.
It's like, how tight is the tuchus?
- The anal hole, yeah.
- I don't know.
I really wasn't looking at
the tightness or anything.
I don't know why-
- But it is important.
- And then I looked at Christy
and I looked at the kids
and I said, "Let's get him."
(laughs)
And they were like,
after all your lectures
about what we were not gonna say
and not gonna do.
- This is the classic story.
- And I knew it was gonna happen.
That's why I told them not to do it.
- You can't go see the dog.
You had to know that you're
gonna bring the dog home.
- 'cause you gotta be like,
man, well, he's got a cone.
That won't last forever.
His legs are never gonna
get shorter, but his face.
His face is so good.
So, we bring him home.
Jade, we want you to meet somebody.
We got somebody new we want you to meet.
Right here, this is,
working title, Jasper.
I've got footage of
introducing him to Jade.
- This is your new home, buddy.
Look over here.
So maybe we put Jade down
and I'll keep holding Jasper.
That's okay.
Look it here.
That's a good girl, Jade.
- [Link] Yeah, and
look, you got a brother.
- That's good.
- Another one.
- [Lincoln] This is good.
- [Link] Look at the cat's tail.
- [Lincoln] Yeah, the
cat's in a defense mode.
- The cat's like, oh boy, here we go.
- [Lily] Here, buddy.
- [Link] Three kids and three kids.
- Oh, yeah.
- Jade is definitely Lando.
Jasper's Lincoln and Saka is me.
- Yeah. You're Saka.
- Nobody likes Saka and Saka likes mildew.
- [Link] So any prediction on who this dog
is gonna love the most?
- Me.
- Hopefully me.
- That's a no brainer.
- Me.
- I'm the alpha.
- Yeah, he completely attached to Christy.
Almost literally, like for
the first couple of weeks,
it was like, he would not leave her side.
He insisted on being carried.
I'm like, this is a problem.
We gotta fix this.
We eventually got him...
We put him in like the
place where we board Jade,
and they also did some
initial training for Jade.
Like we sent him there for
a week to get more training.
So he's a lot better in
terms of being able to walk
and sittin' down and...
- Jasper, sit.
Okay, he's sitting.
Sit.
Sit. Stay.
- Good boy.
- Stay.
- I'm crate training him now
so that he can get over
his separation anxiety.
- Is he pooping in the house?
- Yeah.
I tweeted that I stepped
in some poop barefoot.
That was Jasper from way back.
You gotta sneeze?
- Yeah.
- You're allergic to him.
(Rhett sneezes)
- Oh yeah, I'm allergic to dogs and cats.
So does that mean that the
people who had him before
just didn't even try?
I don't understand.
- I don't know.
And because he doesn't like guys,
I don't know if there was
something else going on
but sometimes they'll give
you more of a sob story
so you'll adopt them, but
I think she could tell
that we were already hooked.
So that was pretty much the end of it.
He and Jade get along.
When Christy sits down on the couch
Jasper is gonna be right
there curled up with Christy.
But then Jade will go over there
and try to get above Jasper on Christy.
- But not aggressive from what I've seen.
- It's just more of like a
hierarchy of positioning.
And then when the cat comes in the room,
they both go after Saka,
but they're all playing
and they're friends.
Jasper, it turns out, really likes Saka,
because well, Lily locked Saka
out of her room by accident,
and Saka couldn't get to his litter box.
And he went under the
kitchen table and crapped.
And it was like a juicy one.
- Oh, cat turds on the ground?
- I wasn't there for
this. They told me this.
But like, I'm like,
"God, that's horrible."
And then Christy said,
"And when I realized
that it had happened, the way I realized
is because Jasper was
over there eating it."
- Oh. Bad boy.
- Gah!
This is the first time
the cat hasn't pooped
in the litter box.
And we're like, "What
the crap are you doing?"
And then she's like googling
and trying to figure out,
what do you do when a
dog eats cat diarrhea?
- Oh, gosh.
I don't even wanna think about this.
- And then he vomits.
- Good.
- It back up
in a different spot.
So now she's cleaning up
cat diarrhea over here
and then vomited dog vomit,
cat diarrhea over here.
- Did you learn your lesson?
- And I'm like, "Christy,
which one smelled worse?"
- Oh gosh.
- It turns out the vomit smell worse.
I didn't know if that
would make it smell better.
- No, it even gets worse.
- Sorry.
Are you happy?
- He's doing really good right now.
- Yeah, I think he's tired.
He's just chilling.
So, you start to learn the things
that make him different from Jade.
And one of the things
is that he's a jumper.
His original name was Kobe.
- Oh, he kinda responded
to that a little bit.
- We've got to change that.
- Hold on, he was Kobe,
but until 11 months old.
- I know. I know.
- This is like a confused little man.
- I was like, I've met the man
and he had a tragic passing.
Those kinda cancel each other out
and make it where, like,
I don't want to name my dog
after a basketball player.
I'm not that into basketball.
And he doesn't jump that much.
On the ride home from
adopting him, I'm saying this.
I'm like, we gotta come
up with another name.
I'm like, "Well, let's just
go with another J name."
Jade was Jade's name
from the adoption agency.
We never changed it.
And I'm like, Lily's
like, "What about Jasper?
Because it's another J
name and it's a rock.
It's a gemstone, just like Jasper."
I'm like, "Ooh, I like that."
- Like Jade, yeah.
- And everybody else is like,
"I don't know about Jasper.
I don't like the name Jasper."
I was like, "It'll grow on you."
It's just a good theme.
We gotta stick to themes here.
We gotta get this out of the way.
By the time we get home,
he's gotta have a new name.
Then we get home, we're
calling him Jasper.
And then I noticed that
like pretty early on,
Christy has shortened Jasper to Jazzy.
She's calling him Jazzy.
So he goes from being Kobe to coming home
to a new family that calls him
two different things that are not Kobe.
- And I called him long
legged, peanut butter, Jade.
- Okay, more and more confusing.
- That's what I wanted to call him .
- Long legged peanut butter Jade.
Sometimes I still do.
I'll call him peanut butter Jade
or I'll call him long
legged peanut butter Jade
or I'll call him long legs.
- Some aggressive...
- He doesn't care.
- Some heavy petting going on here.
- But Christy calls him Jasper or Jazzy.
And I'm like, "Ooh, Jazzy.
We can call him DJ Jazzy
Jeff, after the famous DJ
who is behind all of the
success of "The Fresh Prince."
I've always been a big fan of Jazzy Jeff.
More so than Fresh Prince.
I just felt like he
didn't get enough credit.
He's still doing his thing.
He was a pioneer in the field.
He wasn't just some pop, rap DJ dude
who was along for the ride.
No, he made a lasting impact
on the world of hip hop,
and still does.
I'd love to meet you, Jazzy Jeff.
I named my dog after you.
But I also named him after Jeff Probst.
The best host in the
history of television.
- You have to land on one thing
that you call the dog though.
The dog has a name-
- Jasper DJ Jazzy Jeff Probst.
- You can't call your dog multiple things.
- When we train him, we call him Jasper.
- (laughs) Okay.
So when he is expected to
do something, he is Jasper.
In any other circumstance,
he's something else.
- Yeah.
And look, you can move, or I can mop
the floor with this guy.
- He's kinda like a Smithsonian exhibit.
The way you can just kinda
manipulate him like that.
- Yeah, I know.
See, and this is what I wanted.
And this is what you get
with this type of dog.
It's like, well, I'm just gonna stay here.
He's a love sponge, man.
And he's got this thing we call the face.
Have you seen this?
When he's excited.
So when I come home, he still barks
until he realizes it's me.
And this is why we think
this is a Pomeranian thing
unless he's not Pomeranian,
and then whatever part he is.
This is where this comes from,
'cause Jade doesn't do this.
He will snarl his lips.
- [Rhett] Like a smile a little bit?
- He'll snarl his lips and
move his jaw like this.
When he gets excited, he's
doing this with his lips.
And we call it the face
and we don't like it.
So we always tell him,
"Don't do the face."
- Well, I'm gonna tell you right now.
He doesn't get his long
legs from a Pomeranian.
That's what I thought.
That's what a Pomeranian looks like.
- Well, there's a big mane.
Under that mane, aren't
there like, long legs?
- That's not that long.
These are really long legs.
- Yeah, he's something else.
- Here, look, here's
a Pomeranian with a...
- A fake leg.
- A prosthetic wooden leg.
- Oh man. Jasper.
That could be cool.
- But he could be part of that
because his, I mean,
his face is that color.
- His face is the same as Jade's.
I mean, he's definitely
got some dachshund in him.
Long hair dachshund, but I don't know
what the other thing is.
I mean, doing the genetic
analysis is something that-
- You should do it.
- Just because it's fun to know.
- I mean, 'cause like a
real long haired dachshund
has those really long ears.
And both Jade and him have...
- Shorter ears.
- The short ears.
It comes from something.
- Yeah, we'll have to figure that out.
But the thing that I've noticed
in including him in the family is,
I think I've gone...
Well, I thought I was a
dog person because of Jade,
but I think I was just a Jade person.
Like, I like dogs a lot more
but I've noticed now that Jasper's there
and we're like going
through training again
and trying to get him to cooperate
and learn and understand.
It's like, there's a
reward associated with that
that I hadn't experienced
because I didn't train
Jade that much at all.
And I'm not training him that much.
But even a little bit of
obedience, it's very rewarding.
And I start to feel like I'm moving
from being a Jade lover to
actually being a dog lover.
But Jade will always be my number one.
We started watching this show about dogs
because he started getting into it.
And there's this like
grooming competition show.
It's absolutely obnoxious.
I can't even remember the name of it.
I couldn't get through a whole episode
because the pilot episode,
it was just obnoxious.
But the competition was,
these groomers were given a dog
that looked like what they
called their heart dog,
which is like the first dog
that won their heart over.
So for me, that's Jade.
Jade is my heart dog.
I assume Barbara is going
to be your heart dog.
You won't really know
until you get another dog.
Because all of these people,
their heart dogs had passed away.
And now they still love dogs
and they groom 'em and stuff like that.
But they have this special attachment
to this one dog that
connected with their heart.
And so they brought out these dogs
that looked like their heart dog,
'cause they would show a
picture of, this is so-and-so.
He died in 1986.
And then, but I'm gonna groom
this dog to look like him.
And then they're in tears
grooming these dogs.
- What is this on?
- One of the streamers.
Netflix maybe. I don't know.
But the thing that I
couldn't help but notice
is that none of the dogs-
- Looked like the heart dogs.
- Looked like the heart dog,
yet these people were still bawling.
Like, doesn't he look
just like my munchkin?
And I'm like, "No, he doesn't."
But I think there's like
some sort of blindness.
- I mean, first of all, I'm a dog person
and I've always been a dog person.
But without a doubt connected
much more with Barbara
than any other dog that I've ever had.
If for no other reason
than Barbara's been around
for like what, five years now.
- But she's also your first indoor dog.
- No, no.
We had Murl and Gypsy.
- Oh, that's right. That's right.
- But both of them died within a year.
If you've read the "Book of Mythicality"
you know the dog curse.
But it's interesting because,
I mean, first of all, Jessie
for the entire pandemic
has been, every couple of
nights, she's on the couch,
she's going through the adoption websites.
Like she is big, let's get a second dog.
Jasper, he sheds more than Jade,
'cause I'm seeing his hair go around
and that's why I'm sneezing.
Here's the thing, I'm not
opposed to a second dog.
I know for a fact that I would...
You see those classic
TikToks, which I think,
you kind of represent the
classic dad situation,
which is like, a dad
who's completely opposed
to getting a dog, doesn't
think he likes dogs.
I mean, I've seen like a hundred TikToks
where it's just like dad saying,
"You're gonna have to
take care of this thing."
And then cut to, they play the song
and it's this dad doing
what you're doing with the dog.
And it's like, it's a trope at this point,
but that's not me.
I knew that I was going to be sickeningly
in love with Barbara, say
embarrassing things to her
that sometimes my wife tweets
about what I say to Barbara.
Barbara is my mistress.
She's my girlfriend.
I'm completely in love with her.
And I do want another dog and...
Or I'm open to another dog.
And I don't feel like
it would be this thing
where it's just like,
oh, this dog is replacing Barbara.
I'm so happy and content with Barbara
that I don't feel a need for another dog.
And the thought of the initial
sort of like process of training and...
And first of all, my kids aren't
gonna do anything helpful.
My kids don't help at all
when it comes to this stuff.
Are they saying that they
also want a dog though?
- Of course they want a dog,
because they don't have to do
anything except play with it.
- Yeah. It wouldn't be theirs.
- It would be on me and
Jessie to do the stuff
to make it a good dog.
And I'm just like, I don't know.
I could easily be broken down.
This is not some giant barrier.
- If you went home today and
there was a dog, you would...
- I'd be super happy.
- So is it really, Jessie's not,
she doesn't know if she's ready.
- Well, there's complicating
factors with us.
I don't think we could
have Jasper in the house
because I would be sneezing all the time.
I know there's controversy over this
but hypoallergenic is a thing.
There are dogs that are less
prone to give you allergies.
And they're the ones that
have hair rather than fur,
and I don't know what Barbara is.
She's a mix of some kind.
But she doesn't cause me to start sneezing
when I hang out with her.
So we would need to get a dog
that fits in that category.
But yet we would want to adopt a dog
versus go to a breeder.
So it's like, it kinda complicates
and makes our decision a
little bit more difficult.
But an interesting thing
is, I don't have any desire
for my next dog to look like Barbara,
but I am very interested in
the disposition being the same.
- Once you get used to
one kind, it's easier.
You know what you're dealing with.
It lets you get a baseline.
- I don't have...
The fact that it takes a lot for,
it took a lot for Jade and
it takes more for Jasper
to warm up to people.
And that feels like
more of a project to me.
I don't think Jessie has a lot of capacity
for a project dog.
It's more just like, I
mean, I love Barbara,
but I do understand that
if Barbara were to go
to an Airbnb where somebody else lived
and then we forgot her and left her there
and the other family came home,
she would immediately acclimate
and love them just as
much as she loves us.
Like, she is a endless supply
of attention and cuddling,
but it is not exclusive to us.
- I actually saw it as an advantage to,
almost a download Jasper at 11 months old,
to adopt him at that age,
because yeah, you get the
cuteness of the puppy,
but at least I thought, I mean,
there's a lot more
training that goes into it.
And we were told that he was housebroken.
We also knew that if he's part dachshund,
that like, he's still
gonna sneak off and poop
for the next three years.
- Eat a little cat shit here and there.
- Yeah, that too.
But what we didn't know
was that, okay, you give up
all of the puppy learning curve
and you lose the cuteness,
you get more of the dog that
you know you're gonna be with,
but you also get some sort of,
if there's any emotional baggage or trauma
or something like that.
Like, his separation anxiety
is something that we're dealing with.
And if Christy's goes
out in the front yard
and leaves him in the house,
he's barking and howling.
And like I said, I'm
doing some crate training
to get him better at that.
And you know, in a few months,
I'm sure he'll be a lot better.
But I think ultimately I'm glad
that we got a dog that
was a little bit older.
And Christy is so attached to him
because he needs her so much
that like, she just loves it.
She just eats it up.
And she's like, I mean, she'll say,
"I didn't save him. He saved me."
And I'm like, "Christy, are you doing
what's best for the dog?
Like, you really, you cuddle him so much,
that like, that's not really helping
with the separation anxiety."
You know, it's like, I mean,
she doesn't take a shower
with the dog and we do get
him in the crate now for that.
But yeah, for a while I was
like, "Are you making him worse
because it makes you feel that much better
that he needs you so much?
- Are you saying this is
like a Munchhausen situation?
Or however you say that?
- I don't really know what that is
enough to agree or not.
- That's when, not to make light of it.
This is a real thing that happens.
So it's when a parent
purposely keeps a child sick
so the child is dependent upon them.
- Oh my God.
- It's like the little
girl in "Sixth Sense"
that is under the bed and yeah.
I mean, this happens all the time.
It's like, this kid is
being constantly like,
usually they're poisoning the kid
or doing something to keep the kid sick,
because it creates this
co-dependent relationship
that makes the parent feel
like they've got some self-worth.
So you think your wife is
doing that with your dog?
(laughs)
- Yeah, she's definitely
poisoning the dog.
No.
- She's the one who...
That wasn't cat shit.
That was something Christy
made and said it was cat shit.
- Okay. Yeah.
It seems like Christy and I have something
to talk about tonight.
Okay.
So we got another member of the family.
I don't regret it.
I'm actually feeling pretty good about it.
And I think he's feeling good about it.
He's loving everybody in the house
and he doesn't hate you anymore.
He's just barking at you.
- Yeah, I think the cool
thing about a dog like Jasper
is that there is a...
He presents a challenge.
He just picked something off the ground.
- He tastes a lot of things.
- And it's a challenge that,
I'm okay with that challenge
if it's my friend's dog.
(laughs)
You know what I'm saying?
It's like, I'm trying to
get Jasper to warm up to me.
And one day he will, like
Jade used to bark at me
and now Jade wants to lick
me every time I see her.
It's just the process of making
that transformation happen
is something that I don't know
if I have the patience for my own dog.
So I'm happy for you to do the work
and me to experience the benefit.
- I think you should do it.
I think you need to get another Barbara.
- Well, you know what we did?
It's funny, we went through
this phase with Barbara
where I was so sure,
like, I was talking seriously
about cloning Barbara.
- You loved her that much.
It's not that I love her less.
It was that I hadn't had
a dog in a long time,
hadn't had a dog that I had connected with
to the degree that we've
connected with Barbara.
Began to believe that maybe
the dog curse was over,
especially when she got out
and literally left the house
and jumped into somebody,
a stranger's car and
still came back to us.
At that point, I was like,
okay, maybe the curse is broken.
And we started to think like,
oh, what if we always had
this little white dog?
We always called her Barbara.
'cause there are people who do this.
And it was just like,
let's just do this for the rest of time.
You know, the price of cloning a dog
is dropping every year.
And then I was like, that's crazy.
I mean, I was like, that's crazy
and also insisting on it being Barbara
and looking like Barbara.
No offense to you.
I was like, I feel like I'm giving in
to some unhealthy tendency.
- I'm not gonna clone Jade,
but I do still think about it.
- I let go of that,
and I know that I'll love
the next dog as much.
Jessie wants-
- I just wanted Jade to not be threatened.
I didn't want a new dog
to get more attention.
So. I didn't want an upgrade.
'cause I thought Jade
could pick up on that.
I wanted Jade to stay the queen.
And she's still my dog.
Now this is Christy's dog,
and Jade is still the best.
- Well, the thing that Jessie keeps saying
is that she doesn't want there,
she wants there to be a crossover
between Barbara and the next dog.
And so why not begin the process now?
- Yeah. You're talking
about lifespan here.
- Yeah, she's like the
idea of Barbara dying
and then going through this grieving phase
and then finding another dog,
which I think there's an
argument to be made there.
But Barbara is only five years old.
She's a little dog.
She's gonna, probably at least be 12, 13,
maybe significantly older, I don't know.
I don't know.
I'm sure we'll get
another dog at some point,
and I'm sure I'll love it
just as much as I love Barbara.
I mean, well, maybe a little
bit less than Barbara.
- A little bit less.
- A little bit less than Barbara.
- I don't think I'm ever gonna
love a dog as much as Jade.
And I don't want to.
I can give you a rec though.
It's totally related.
I said we were watching
that dog grooming show.
The reason why Lando got me to watch that,
'cause he thought I'd be into it,
is because he had gotten
me into another show
that I'm recommending called
"Canine Intervention."
"Canine Intervention," it's
kind of like "Dog Whisperer,"
if you're familiar with that show.
But I actually haven't watched that show.
- Cesar?
- Yeah, Cesar's show.
But it's like, you got problem dogs
that then this guy, I call him Jas.
It's J-A-S, like short for Jason, maybe.
But the way that he says
his name is like, Johs.
- Okay, that's weird.
That's a little weird.
- They don't say his name enough
for me to get it straight in my head.
But it's this guy from Oakland
who travels all around California
and helps with troubled troubled dogs.
And like, he's got this training facility.
And the way they do these shows now,
it's like, all right,
there's a story of these dogs
and it's really compelling,
like tears in my eyes
watching these dogs transform.
That's the other thing
that made it click for me
was like, I wanted to watch this show
because I'm trying to help train Jasper.
But then I'm connecting
to all these dog stories
and I'm like weeping.
It's a really good show.
And then at the end, like
with all these reality shows,
you see him back home with his family
talking about like,
oh, they got a newborn.
And then they got these
seemingly ferocious dogs
that are just so well-trained
and all around the baby.
And so you get to know their home life
and his professional life.
And he's just got such a-
- It's called "Canine Intervention?"
- "Canine Intervention,"
but it's super cool.
I mean, the stories are really good.
It's really well produced.
And that's my rec.
If you're into dogs, you
should definitely watch it
because all of the stories
and transformations
are inspirational and moving.
- All right, "Canine Intervention?"
- Yeah.
- Thanks for listening.
Send my wife links to dogs that you think
that we should adopt and oh #EarBiscuits.
- You know not what you ask for.
- #EarBiscuits.
(laughs)
- All right, we'll speak at you next week.
Let us know what you
think about adopting dogs,
second dog adoption experience,
all this stuff if you relate to it.
#EarBiscuits.
Next week, we're gonna be
unearthing all our ideas
in traditional entertainment
that were squashed.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.
(upbeat music)